hi i'm chris is number one fan Tessa and
I'm Tessa's dumb one fan Chris hello I'm
Karen Gillan I'm Jack Black
haha James McAvoy Emma Thomas and Jake
Gyllenhaal Will Smith Sarah Paulsen Miss
Pratt more lights indicating Kristen
Stewart Jesse lingard Alan Scott Tinie
Tempah and we're gonna be playing first
impressions bye
[Music]
you should go first I don't really know
what era
is so embarrassing oh gosh I'm literally
gonna turn the color she goes like if it
just keep it going I have a gumbo so you
don't confuse them good well I'm gonna
go ahead and order to carry-out
I think I don't know what's wrong with
me that was so good I need to watch
everyone's now I'm gonna become like a
huge fan of this show I don't want to be
king oh no let's see yeah you know mind
it was Whitney's going mmm oh it's a bit
of a surfer oh no no close close
oh yeah Thorpe
that's great that was really good yeah
you're you saying tribute right oh yes I
just um I don't let me think okay okay
I was I was worse than this this is so
embarrassing you know I just especially
you know I just I feel like we should
just just don't even think about it
let's not even think let's just go
is this an impression yes dude and you
just said this is even was then me wait
are you doing me oh god I thought you
were just freaking out yeah because of
me
yeah because that makes sense yeah yeah
I was like god this is what I look like
when I'm freaking huh oh man well good
job that actually was great it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a laugh
[Laughter]
no idea hyena dolphins nose
I used to freaked my mom out when I was
young like oh but I just think a lot of
incredibly sexy and married to a very
important of the purposes sure and I'm
like the Queen if the whole an army and
everything I'm America
sexy and Beyonce knows okay the boobs
fear because well come on yeah irenna
her boobs are great well and she does
lift them in a way oh no no no it's a
crab no no could you hit me could you
actually heavy really yeah could you hit
me one more time
so um I'm from America and I talk like
this and uh you know everything I say is
kind of you know quite husky like this
and you know he's a jackass I don't like
that guy yeah that could be any American
okay you know I was in a very powerful
position one of the most powerful in the
country hey guys my name what's-his-face
Chris Pratt yeah the worst crews I know
hey guys good friend here you know
you're a dancer uh off the top of my
head yes and it runs but the thing is
that I'm coming up with it from the top
of my head and I make it up I make it up
yes but what is that call when you're
rapping improvising come on
[Music]
we're in London we're going down the
street to a funky beat oh and I'm gonna
get a haircut oh I wanted to say oh okay
here we go
I don't want to do this without doing
something that I'm gonna get in trouble
you know that first time that I bought
but the Douglas yay knocked me out but
you know then I took it out on event the
Holyfield's ear and so I came out and um
and all I knew how to do with fight you
know what I'm saying
so I'm still fighting well hello there
dear we're going to do your house gonna
come clean I'm clean your hers there oh
not maryberry right here no dear Miss
Doubtfire I noticed when I still issues
my mom all right listen I just want to
talk to you about out what I feel about
the baby okay oh the other one yeah
they'll give me a mighty donor give me a
bite you can get me by Holly Hunter yeah
this is another famous tiger this way um
I'm the dumbest character in the lego
movie you know I got batarangs and this
is a dangerous game yeah it's a very
dangerous game obviously that was
supposed to be me
I just want to do this all day
yeah that was fun right how's the best
one so far you guys so far thank you